hello everybody first question
so Patricia Marco chia and mozzie are
hoaxes the event in Montreal which I
graciously accepted - my name is
Jonathan pego you see that I you will
see my face in this movie I I haven't
seen it so I don't know don't don't
start hunting me off the tour I no idea
but I've been hearing really good things
about the documentary so I'm excited to
see it with you guys i if you don't know
a little bit the story of the movie
Patricia was filming a documentary about
her Peterson and his relationship with
his friend Charles who was Native
American and who's a carver and Jordan
and this man had developed a very close
relationship to the extent that Jordan
was adopted into his family so Patricia
was filming this story as the events
around her Houston erupted and that's
why she got this inside scoop on the
event and Patricia and I GRE of this
very normal liberal left-leaning people
and c'mon oh all of a sudden for
let's see this crazy whirlwind around
him and are trying to make sense of why
such extreme positions are being taken
regarding him
and so the documentary was kind of
slowly built up as he was in this world
when filming things you know filming the
events and putting it together she's
still actually trying to put together
the the documentary based on Jordans
relationship with trouble which should
come up hopefully I think their
crowdfunding right now for that
and so I'm ignoring a few years ago
again also before this world when I
heard him on CBC you know and I was
really excited about some of his ideas
about psychology how the understood
religion how he understood some of the
problems were facing and myself as well
was caught up in this crazy story all
the sudden all these extreme position
being pulled on each side of him and and
so I just been following the story just
as you guys and I'm excited to see how
Patricia and mozzie are going to tell
the story so after the event I'm going
to give a short question and answer
obviously I can't answer everything
about computers and I'm not going
Peterson there's a lot of things about
the man that I love
much I also have my criticisms of him as
I'm sure all of you do and the great
thing about dort is actually is willing
to make those criticisms so if you have
questions for me at the end I will stick
around and be willing to answer some
questions so enjoy the movie so if you
guys have if you if there's something
you want to ask me obviously like I said
I can't enter I can't I'm not Jordan
Peterson I can't answer for him but I
can try to answer as best as I can the
questions you have see what was it you
kissed you on message if any of one of
us said if you ask a question in English
and I'll answer in English so anybody
has something they want to ask um I
don't know how how they receive it right
now but one thing is for sure is that
this movie was made out of a CBC special
and I'm so you saw the CBC spectrum and
so for them it actually was an
opportunity to to put in the content
that they had wanted to put in because
in the CBC special they obviously were
somewhat you know they were under the
CBC they had certain requirements that
they had to fill and so making this
movie was a way for them to do that
which to put in more content that they
wanted to put in so maybe there's if
there's some content that they wanted to
put in that it
I don't know well see these I don't know
CBC they had a certain angle that they
wanted they did it in the way that you
know I don't know I don't know I don't
want to answer that but it was also very
short and they felt like they couldn't
get everything they wanted to get out
into that into that video so so this was
kind of the way that they could expand
the discussion and make it bigger what
the movie I think it's fair I think that
how can I say this I would say that it's
hard it's hard because Jordan is such a
polarizing figure and he's my friend so
I I think it's fair in the sense that I
feel like they presented the people that
were closest to him that criticized him
I felt like the criticism that they
posed they they put up some of the more
controversial things that you've said so
I feel like they were able to show a
little bit of the controversy around him
some of the things you said that were
kind of edgy kind of on the edge but at
the same time I I feel like what comes
out is very positive but that's also
because of my own what I bring to it as
well
just focusing so much on Jordans
polarizing effect that his ideas like
his deep ideas fallen to the wayside
like having seen his biblical things and
his thoughts on alchemy and maps of
meaning like all his deep spots you find
he's frustrated that he spent so much
time talking about that stuff but he
loses out on investigating those ideas
further with people um I think they
pause okay all right so he asked if the
polarization around Jordan if it maybe
is taking away from what is really deep
messages in terms of his understanding
of religion is insights into alchemy
into different aspects of reality
if this polarizing effect is taking away
from that I think that I think that it's
a deep how can I say this it's like a
50/50 thing we're on the one hand I
think Jordan is a very smart person and
extremely can I say this he's very
tactical and so he was able also to use
this controversy that he didn't expect
to be able to talk about the things that
he really so he said he said that Jordan
has some insights on prophetic dreams
and in the video it's shown to make it
look a bit crazy but that is something
that Jung has talked about well I think
in that section and we're really trying
to show the point of view of the person
his friend who criticized him so I think
that's probably why it came out that
but uh I just said just a follow-up
ready big part of the Greek philosopher
yeah so you asked if I know how dort is
doing because he's a he's worried um
yeah and his wife I it was very strange
because I was having very short you know
I had this kind of short little email
exchanges with him you know we write
notes back and forth after a few months
and I've been really following Tami's
story and and so when things started to
get better I got a note from him and he
was saying that it seemed like it was
getting better and it was kind of this
strange surprising event you know they
don't really know exactly how it is that
it happened but she's getting better and
then I learned about his own problems
through Mikayla's video like most of us
did and so since then I I kind of waited
a little bit I send it was a small short
message he didn't answer but I don't
know I don't know what he's I think that
Jordan is a very he's very smart and he
realized his what was going on in terms
of the medication that he was taking and
he probably just said okay I need to nip
this in the bud because he wants to get
back he's writing another book he has so
many things that he wants to do so he
just wants to get rid of this problem
and then move on that's the way I
perceive it but I don't know Ivan I
haven't had any firm in sense
okay so he's saying that he heard an
update today that it was a big reaction
- yeah I'll have this fringe medication
for anxiety that he was reacting - yeah
that's that's what I heard as well and
then she's checked if he checked himself
into a rehab center to be able to kind
of just get it out of his system and and
and move on am I correct in my
understanding if this is the only
showing of this documentary so he asked
if it's the only showing of the
documentary Canada no it's going to be
shown in several places in Canada it's
going to be I think the only showing in
Montreal but you know it got shut down
in Toronto because someone who works for
the movie theater complained about how
country how some things were were
offensive and now it just got shut down
in New York or they did one showing in
New York and it was sold out and then
they said okay so we're gonna add
another showing and it was shut down
that
Maziar send me a message just this
morning to tell me so it's crazy because
when you watch a documentary it's hard
to imagine that someone could have
presented a fair representation
considering that it is about drug person
than it is a video it is it is the
documentary about him but that there is
this desire to fairly show all the sides
that despite that there's still this
desire to still shut him down so so so
she asked what was offensive I don't
know I don't know what was offensive I
mean
I think it had to do with the same issue
that from the beginning that to do it
with with with the transgender questions
so says expression is something that
affects us here in Canada but is not
necessarily something that is affected
people in south of the border I think
it's a question that is being posed
right now
you know if there's so many confluence
of events that are bringing this whole
freedom of expression question social
media the internet all these things have
opened up the door for all kinds of
possibilities of expression that we
didn't realize that were before
anonymous you know like all these
anonymous people online that say the
wildest things because they're anonymous
all these things they didn't exist for
them so this is all new and no people
are trying to figure out how do we deal
with this how far do we let it go you
know and so it's a it's a difficult it's
a difficult problem but it's sure that
in the u.s. people aren't protected by
the Constitution itself and so they're
you know those that are for freedom of
speech they have something to stand upon
where whereas in Canada we don't have
that constitutional stand we just have a
kind of common law or a common vision of
what how we imagine freedom in a Western
society but not necessarily it's not as
ingrained in our culture for sure yes
sir so he asked if the film will be
available online yes they are
negotiating right now is for sure it's
going to be on Apple iTunes and they're
negotiating with other streaming
platforms
he's asking for a movie poster I don't
know so he asks because the movie didn't
deal with your biblical series he's
asking me if about that if I if we've
talked about it if there's something
what I think about the biblical series I
think that doors biblical series during
pinnacle series are on the one hand is
amazing
this amazing thing that came about where
here's this professor talking about the
Bible
trying to get to the deepest meaning
that you can find in the Bible and
millions of people watching it and it's
and it's just astounding that first
video about what is God I mean I think
it's it's got millions of views by now
so I thought it was just astounding and
then about the biblical lectures
themselves sometimes he says great
amazing things and sometimes he says
things that are questionable sometimes
he says things that are kind of just we
don't know where he gets them from and
and if like sounds like this wild roller
coaster and yeah that's Jordan Peterson
that's your medicine he is like I'm
gonna take you on this trip that I'm on
and I'm not sure where exactly where I'm
going I'm gonna ride this and I'm going
to to pay attention to what people are
saying and I'm going
I'm willing to change my opinion if I'm
saying something too weird and so he so
when you watch the video if you like
sometimes sometimes like wow this
amazing insight and then where is he
going
what's he said I don't understand why
he's going there and no wow this amazing
insight so that's how I feel about his
biblical series I would love to have
more time to talk to him about that but
to be honest Jordan has become I mean if
Tammy says that she's lost him to the
world for sure I think all of his
friends feel similar like I have little
tidbits little emails from Jordan and
and he regrets it he says you know I'm
sorry I'm not able to be more present
but that's that's reality yeah I haven't
seen Jordan in I guess since 2000 late
2008 early 2018
so I just want to clarify that free
speech is one thing in Canada the
freedom of expression is an entirely
other thing so I would encourage
everybody to raise some freedoms thank
you so he said that we do have a Charter
of Rights and Freedoms and he encourages
everybody here to see what the what arch
Canadian Charter says about freedom of
speech
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
Madame an experienced commercial chicken
meat director Madhan Verma modernity jjz
transitory male-centric contact a
whiskey tax Schedule D diversification
atomic older geomatica lives and Dwight
Yoakam a crochet edge or del bosque a
javelin developer the personals at work
Canada via Nepal is so common necessary
ruyan grtt Sabrina nationals here
Mexico City video shows washi
inexperienced personal version
Katie Tati Pergamum Alex can extend one
ramappa remedies the newness it is the
text and one key across the Jordan
Pederson some revenue than there are
some normal 200 workers at his community
today we travel - Femi tea soda
volcanoes avatar suit support support
dispenser the nationalist dance there is
what review GG Janet Jackson chemotactic
in Moroccan villa stock of coins of
bougie the next M that I sold my next
ahem
weight equal to 1/6 and if they were
mostly she will be thicker
whose stupid such as a person did
shipment me remain yummy and I may avoid
additional recommended from the dead
town get a battery badly yep a Sony
Tablet or Evalia body it can skeet a
conservator it should oppressor epitope
you a big a big person about flag if it
not review and again we need certificate
Wilma DC comic opera Brad we are not on
the kitchen me lemon he only a pelican
ferocity care about you are worsted oil
and the conference epidemic a tear mayor
but Allah was in Syria specifically
policy the zone the metal a metal coated
exactly welcome Logan
meesa meesa sama complement soft when
you san jose-madurai stages accepted to
good amount a disability deeds must
teach with steamers reported back
special few substantial Kenosha emulsion
has issued to mount monk riser a gloved
well-kept a steeple integrity supporters
the community for metalic point it's too
powerful a vasila no no but it's it so
you see a lot of people what's next for
this because it seems like maybe it was
a bit of a like this big event that
happened a lot of attention and I might
be wrong but maybe it's starting to so I
wonder like what do you think has been
at happen next what's the next change in
the culture how are we gonna shake so he
asked what's next he says it did Jordan
Peterson event was a moment and he's
bringing people back to fixing up their
lives I'm back to faith all these things
but he asked what would we do now
because of course it's a wave and the
wave feels like it's kind of going down
although my goodness every time I think
I adjourn jury to speak and then it's
like okay learn more it's like one more
really in the pit anyway but it's true
it's a white it's going to fade it's
just like any phenomena at some point
it's going to reach some height and it's
going to fade and I think that think
that's when that's when we need to take
what you saying the best things of what
we saying to take them at Harvard to
this us now right it's if it's all it's
our job to make our lives better to make
our families better to make our
immediate communities better and work on
that you know and have real
relationships and real and that's that's
the next step because that even that's
what he says is the only thing that's
going to save our culture is if you know
if you take care of the people around
you and you love your neighbor instead
of being on Twitter fighting some you
know and Jordan is guilty
like metier metier mentioned like he's
he he does it and then I mean sometimes
he's told me he said he said okay I have
to his son will take away his Twitter
rights because he guess he just gets
caught up and even myself he thought he
kept telling he's like it says on
Twitter
don't answer anybody that you don't
follow or else you're serious trouble
like just don't do it it's not it just
drags you into these emotions and it's
not worth it and he's not perfect he's
falling into that hole you saw some put
those crazy tweets thank you and so he's
done it himself and and I'm sure if you
ask him he'd be like aw man I can't
believe I did that you know he's very
reasonable in that sense so I think it's
us the only thing I can say
[Music]
- TV ad Jordan take your sumela pretend
that sugar on it
no get show ck sick father said the
sketch were system the photo shows the
possum Kuja confessor is just an act now
to the second Thomas shoal O Matic poor
Maggie - gee sonic new comforter it's
the more cash per tick can stick a Cathy
could see Superman these are ma the
ricotta cake can't trigger
good jello you sign up of work according
this is it jump feet swing it could be
educated when hockey hockey is work
castles the you critical such director
shows he him
Tuesday we see mechanical and treat sick
see through the foreman joke my election
ticket either visa cash but a comics
authenticity daca Rican bath son Daniel
coupe is like a spec cooker yes inside
difficulty on may accept and this is the
electric air she's just put a cop - yes
- Tenzin - Akio do you can see a nice
fish it's coffee cup or she said it if
something that's Pentecost Monday on
this bizarre case past Kemal the postman
is your pleasure to chose GTD focused on
TC a second opinion
kisses potaka maipi skills ski geniality
glory seeker see connect much it isn't a
motion to attempt the it's a cheap cheap
it'll do a big rebel wisdom which it
dissipate your fears and the heretic
allergic John just exist at the time and
it takes the puts to get a device watch
I'm going to divide Jordan today Jordan
here's me calling your hair take ha ha
ha
that's when one certification went on
any Apocrypha that guard existing you
really perform of war that's catalytic
up you bleep take see sister so cities
and yeah shows ketchup listen Tuesday
take care magnetic as per the amount
amount research looks at another come to
us when I meet a porn web he come are
not forgotten Elsa get the service have
a perfect is on empty havoc Jordan the
cervix is occasionally
[Music]
but aa non-sexual Isaac now the waka
Japan new PowerPoint 602 on a church
possibly possibly curses so security
: balaclava make special because it's up
Yan Yan me Baskar city so the term
recruited the other problem da the zone
Lakota response acute totally this is a
temple Suki Suki of amid dukes with you
first meet the rest in the same beliefs
assessment area sleepless Suzuki
mechanically at Jordan she said visual
sense a capacity the world among
advocate is to regard aluminum
acceptance to through the compound
Kumasi scripture escape air versus Akeno
axially very respected local tea party
and all the al-aqsa supposably
may I meant that this must be done
suppose the document I'll support those
key to dish the garbage ket maysa from
one
well I know for a fact that Jordan
Peterson stances is such that that
differs depending on how people view him
as an individual but I do believe that
Jordan Peterson's stance kind of tends
towards understanding that in politics
or in the political spectrum that
there's people out there in the world
that want to go over in the top of the
biking man in the community for other
individuals so that people cannot freely
express themselves or identify
themselves in a certain manner without
them having to go through some form of
conflict or some type of law sorry
aggression a to suffer some sort towards
a certain group right the monetize
movement and I think that that's what he
is fighting for in my opinion so I want
to ask you right there's a movie that's
coming out you will hurt you're out of
the joke a movie that's coming out right
you've heard that there are people that
are not necessarily feeling a certain
way about the movie due to the fact that
it's so clear they bother and it
encourages certain people on a certain
side to view that particular movie in a
way that's opposed encourage them to do
the exact same thing that's happening
within that amount of the movie but do
you believe that people are more than
capable of trying to follow something
like that as if it's like a blueprint
yeah so he asked well I mean he said
something about nobody ended up asking
about the dobra movie and what I think
in terms of how there's this crazy
reaction to the Joker movie and how it's
going to be a blueprint for certain
people to act a certain way I think it's
hilarious I mean I think it's I'm sorry
I think it's funny because it just came
out like two weeks ago
they're not about a clown that killed
children and then two weeks later
there's this Joker movie but now this is
the movie that is being targeted it's
there's a I haven't seen the movie I'm
gonna go see it for sure now for sure
we'll see it and I might do I might do a
YouTube interpretation of it because I'm
trying to understand what is what is
happening in the culture so that this
movie was targeted for this kind of
weird political pressure that we're
seeing it's very strange I think it's
quite funny that you mention about the
if it would be because I've also heard
that somebody made a post about a
trigger warning for those who are of the
LGBT community right specifically those
in the I guess L of the G right due to
the fact that a gay couple in the MU
chapter 2 got hurt in a certain way okay
and they said that it was traumatizing
so if anybody feels a certain way they
shouldn't watch the movie because of
that
he asks about these political leanings
of the people who made the movie and he
wonders if it had tinged the movie and
whether or not you know because there's
a lot of other people besides ordinary
and everything I mean that they're I
mean they might watch this movie so I'm
gonna say Patricia and I mean they're
just regular left-leaning artistic types
from Toronto Patricia was new Jordan
from before and she got they got all
caught up in this and so they they're
trying to figure it out on for
themselves as well like where do they
stand in terms of kind of these
left-leaning people in this question of
free speech and this question of Jordan
because they obviously like him to
admire him but they're trying to
understand it so so yeah they do have
their own political leanings but um I
don't think another I don't think that
another version of this movie could have
been made and it would be playing in
theaters this movie is already being
shut down so if any other type of movie
and made oh my goodness so he has as
someone who's been in technology record
is still he is symbology what would I do
Jordan warrant against doing that he
said several times that you never should
become an architect because it'll kill
you I have said several times that I
think that Jordan is a and I say that in
the movie as well that he's an
in-between figure and that's why he's
receiving all the scorn from both sides
right so he doesn't fit he's kind of
like this strange figure I've said he's
something like I like John the Baptist
or or someone like Elijah these weird
figure that are kind of out of place and
and there's telling everybody pay
attention pay attention you know
Elijah's Elijah's Georgia started st.
John the Baptist Maine saying was you
know it's usually like the voice crying
out in the wilderness right make
straight the waves for the Lord
it's basically saying clean your room
that's the thing tell the guys the
things in your room right so that
something bigger could happen and so
that if I would reduce drug Peterson to
one thing I would say he's kind of a
weird John the Baptist figure weird
so he asked if I was worried that
something would happen here no I was not
worried that something would happen here
and the reason why I was not worried is
because George is not that known here
do you notice he didn't come to Montreal
on his death of rules for the pitch what
lose but I francophone culture has not
really kind of seen him on the horizon
so I think that that he has too little
attention to draw any higher in yeah I
thought it was just because of the fact
that this is more of me I would say
someone more than a conservative type
where that Ontario especially Toronto's
more liberal
yes why I think Jordan is not picking up
with our Quebec francophone culture I
think one of the reasons is because a
lot of the a lot of the kind of crazy
postmodern stuff like they're really
really intense it's just not cured at
least not yet so there's some inkling of
it we see it a little bit but it's not
it's not this massive it's not a massive
in Quebec so I think that a lot of the
things that Jordan ders is saying at
least for now it's not really resonating
because we don't have it as much here
that's my perception
[Music]
janaka's see Jordan they see getting my
job back and he said what what she might
say today missus just be your book you
put that down show me see the muscle
it's only the 12 rules for life Afghan
says you cut school about
so he asks if he's working but yeah yes
yeah he he he wrote if you know the 12
rules for thy book was a condensation of
an answer that he wrote on Quora and it
was that it was like kind of
40-something answer it's like 50 antes
or something and so he's gonna write
he's just going to take those other a
lot of those other rules that he that he
wanted to talk about and make a like a
CEO of his worldview or view the world
like that I think he has like this idea
in terms of purpose like that he's kind
of intuition based like your ideal and
you will kind of you should you know
what you should do yeah and I think one
time he said you know kind of follow
that ideal unless you have the level of
bottom
so he's asking me what I think is
missing in George Peterson I think that
I think that because Jordan is is so
worried about totalitarian thought
because he's so wary of totalitarian
thought he really focus on the
individualism and the danger of that is
that it can become that can become
individualism and we've had enough
individualism in the world right you've
had enough of fragmented individuals who
just are on their own and I know that's
not what you wanted and I know I don't
want you distorted message I know that's
not what you want but sometimes he will
point to the fact that this is these
communions of individuals it has to
scale up it has to scale up into
communities and scale up into something
more right and so the difficulty of that
is that that does end up looking
something like identity now the question
is how do we do that so that it's not
dangerous and that it's not toxic how
can we create communion without the
danger of the tough the totalitarian
extreme and I think that that's
something that he doesn't really talk
about a lot and so I mean obviously I
think I come from my own side I I
believe that that's what when they did
did and he says that too right he says
that that too that would that's what
religion used to do but he's not willing
to like he doesn't want to say that it
still could still be possible and that
made for me that's the big that's the
big gap I would say
individualism yeah that is exactly
that's exactly the way that he frames it
and I think that there's some value to
that which is he's saying I'm not
telling people individuals that they
have to take on all on themselves that
they have to take on the responsibility
on themselves and not you know not focus
on their rights and their privileges and
I agree but I still need I still don't
see how in his system it scales up I
mean I think it does but yeah
whether it is he would take his message
board to the main shipping culture like
honey West tweeted about computers and
haven't like waiting for impossible very
political yeah no III think that he's
all he would definitely do that for sure
I mean he's sold three million books
that's not that's not an academic level
of discussion that's like to have a
Kanye West or infinity I'm waiting for
them I've been waiting for I've been
waiting for that interview from before I
did Gordon sorry I've been waiting for a
kind
all right maybe yeah harder for me this
hardening was the senior professor who
wrote the article yeah I think becoming
a dangerous be here more than that it
was when he said that Jordan was trying
to reach out multiple times
do you think that most people received
or it appears that someone who wasn't
genuinely have we debated conversations
with them or is just someone who's just
listening so he says the discovery was
disheartening part was the part when his
friend wrote that article and then
wasn't going to take towards calls
despite the fact Iran is calling on
comió they asked about how people
perceive I mean I don't know how people
perceive your inclusive for sure I think
that like I said my experience of him is
that he's the real deal
like he's what you see he's not
pretending he wants he wants to have as
much real contact that when he's like he
tears up he's not it's not theater he's
he's actually genuinely touched by
whatever effect he's able to have and to
see people get their lives together and
to see people mend their relationships
and that's like he's he's he really
wants that to happen so people that
don't like him in there that are that
have already made up their minds at this
point I don't think they're gonna change
I don't think they're gonna change their
mind and Jordan has been saying now for
a year that he means he wants to stop
doing interviews just because it's so
exhausting you guys won't realize like
when he does an interview with that like
the committee does one of those
interviews like that french guy that you
saw and they never you like just how
arrogant he is and kind of like and
Jordan is out three days after that cuz
he just he doesn't want that he doesn't
like that [ __ ] he hates it he hates
these kind of conflictual conversations
people think that he's looking for them
that he someone gets a rise out of this
conflict he despised him and so when he
has to face this thing he's gonna face
it but then it like it just it just
Wrexham and so
he's been even saying that he wants to
get away from that for a while I don't
they'll be able to say says one of the
biggest criticisms of Jorn is that he's
a bit of a Rorschach test
and what's my thought about that I I
think that you're I think that you're
not totally wrong I think that that's
one of that's what it one of those
that's what an intermediary character is
the intermediary character is a
character that isn't totally defined and
you project into that character and
that's why people are projected into him
because it's crazy it's like the type of
things people are saying you know I know
people that have told me you know
extreme right people who regularly
people who write me and say how can you
even talk to him
he's a he's a globalist he's a show he's
an Illuminati he's you know he's all
that then and then someone else is
saying that he's a Nazi that he's you
know that he's a horrible misogynist
racist all this stuff so it's like how
can he be fits to extremes at the same
time but that's the thing that's that's
why he's attracting that a program
that's why he's attracting that because
he has he is this weird intermediary
character and so he is a Rorschach test
I agree I agree
that's what I feel that is quite intense
and it does loosen and authentic that's
what I get out of him sometimes I've
seen it with some interviews in that and
thinking you're so smart man and you
know this gothic just break it down he
doesn't break it down my mind sometimes
it doesn't know I would receive he
doesn't know how to close the gap he
knows the other person is he's going off
of it or like yes yeah yes sir she says
she says sometimes you see them in
interviews and she feels like he
couldn't connect things like you
couldn't he could he could bring things
together but that he doesn't they be
smart that he should and he doesn't and
it's you know all I can say about that
is how many of us have ever been in a
public discussion where someone is
attacking like I have never been in that
situation you know where you're on air
you know there's gonna be a million
people watching and now the person is
going after you it's like how do you
even react to that so I think that a lot
of it is that is just trying to stay
cool just think oh my goodness
it's like it doesn't get angry a lot I
would you know you could imagine just
just saying this is it
this is what this interview is done to
you bad intentions I'm out of here
it's like but so so I think a lot of it
is that it's just just tough yeah maybe
and how holy perceive that community as
we often do straight so there's this
multi-dimensional phenomena that is
tradition where you have and then you
have the person was just trying to be
true to his balance and sometimes it's
gone you know I was thinking and you're
saying what we're seeing is that he had
this fight that's going for him again
like what is again a student species for
within speech and that's what the grass
means getting focused on right but I
sort of appreciate use to believe that
all his other aspects one of which is
book about bettering yourself generate
across to that community and if it does
why
oh so he says that he feels like after
Friday can then 27th he said it feels
like that often now it's presented that
he's talking it seems like it's against
the trans community but that there are
all these complex
he's a very multifaceted figure you know
father figure psychologists all these
things and you know like his book of
rules for life is wondering why you know
people in the trans form you could use
some of the things that are said that
there's nothing like there's nothing
about trans people in that book it's
it's it's a book about how to make your
life better and why they're not willing
to say the there isn't that connection
and though I don't know I mean I don't
know how to make who it is because I
don't know I'm not in that community I
you know I think that there's a lot of
people that are very vocal in that
community which don't send represent the
whole community there are people who are
just doing their thing and they're just
trying to live their lives so it's like
I don't I don't have that quick at that
so maybe so maybe this could be the last
one because I saw the guy from the
cinema come in look at me oh yeah oh so
maybe I can make an announcement too
especially 12 Alessa across the street
so I I'm also I also cuz I done doing
this YouTube thing and it's I feel like
you know how this lady said did you need
to do real people think so what I want
to start doing is I also want to start
to organize some kind of discussion in
French
probably so his only to Quebec so I'm
probably gonna want to do something you
guys all the only speaking people
getting to find all kinds of special but
I probably wanted to start a French
speaking kind of discussion group to
talk about about a lot of the issues
that George bring it up about
spirituality about you know even
politics I'm not a big
we can talk about politics too so if
you're interested in that possibility
you can write me I have my business
cards you I can give you a card you can
write me an email and I'll try to just
set something up for those who are
interested in that maybe hopefully even
starting next month so if you're
interested in that kind of discussion
you can come up see me and all right
guys thank you for coming if you enjoy
the symbolic world content there's a lot
of things you can do to help us out and
not subscribe please do go ahead and
share this to all your friends if you
can get involved in the discussion we
have a Facebook group in which people
can talk about these subjects I will put
all those links in the description and
also if you can please support us
financially by going to my website
www.jfn.co.jp/toho